ich habe auch ein thema mitgebracht was
nicht geil ich gesagt amüsiert und zwar
wollen die berliner jusos dass lehrer in
der schule nicht mehr gesucht werden
sondern dass sie geduzt werden ich frage
mich was soll der staat dennoch alles
entscheiden also die blinke regelwut die
viele linke so gerne für den staat
hätten die zeigt sich jetzt wieder aber
müsste es nicht dem lehrer selbst
obliege aber duzen oder siezen wir oder
der schule selbst wie kann es sein dass
die berliner jusos fordern das einfach
mal lehrer besser genutzt werden das ist
für mich eine regelungswut die ich nicht
will es ist für mich auch mal wieder
konträr zur freiheit und damit herzlich
willkommen
ja nicht nur jungs mut das ist auch eine
sache verkehrt ich meine kinder müssen
den respekt vor erwachsenen lernen das
lernen sie heute immer weniger wenn man
sieht wie kinder erzogen werden häufig
erzogen werden wie unerzogen sie durch
die welt laufen wie wenig sie andere
achten und auf sie rücksicht nehmen das
ist eine aufgabe der schule und ich
finde bevor die jusos sowas vorschlagen
sollten sie sich mal darum kümmern dass
der senat in berlin funktioniert das
hier wahlen funktionieren dass ein
flughafen in der lage ist menschen
innerhalb von drei stunden weg zu
transportieren und nicht vier stunden
vorher ein zu bestellen weil sie sonst
im flieger verpassen es ist bizarr was
in dieser stadt diskutiert wird zwischen
den parteien da gehört das auch dazu
extrem bizarr während hier nichts
funktioniert was den menschen am leben
hielt ich glaube auch das ist schade ist
und wir können bestimmte hierarchien in
der gesellschaft nicht abschaffen indem
wir einfach das sie verbieten das ist ja
absolut ich glaube auch dass schüler
dann keinen respekt mehr haben vor vor
den lehrern und ich stelle mir vor es
wäre auch eine abstrafung der alten
eigentlich wir würden denen dann keinen
respekt mehr zahlen und außerdem ist es
doch hervorragend dass wir im deutschen
eine höflichkeit formel haben die wir ja
der englischen sprache voraus haben
warum sollten wir die also abschaffen
ich finde es eigentlich wunderbar es
gibt eben sprachen wo ist die
unterscheidung gar nicht gibt in
schweden ist auch üblich dass sich die
menschen duzen sich auch alle erwachsen
eines beispiels ganze welt nutzt sich
aber in schweden wir haben eine andere
sprache und wir haben eben deutsch
und da haben wir das sie und dass du und
das sollten wir auch pflegen und das
müssen kinder lernen da bin ich tut mir
leid altmodisch ich denke hoch und dann
sieht man sich bei der polizei also
unter kollegen duzt man sich mit den
vorgesetzten sie ist man sich dass sich
polizeipräsident wird auch gesehen
selbstverständlich wird der mehrwert
raus ob er wert darauf legt dass weiß
ich nicht aber ich lege großen wert
darauf weil man genau diese zwei
vokabeln respekt und und höflicher
umgang miteinander weiter pflegen sollte
so amüsant was die was die jusos so von
sich geben in der vergangenheit
mittlerweile nimmt das aber auch die
bitte an wo man sagt da muss man echt
mal drüber nachdenken ob das alles noch
so zeitgemäß ist was die im moment
gerade veranstaltungen wie sie sagten
gerade und ich sitze ja auch
das können aber sofort ändert wenn es
ihnen nicht schade ja nein also das
sollten wir schon räuber die gewisse
distanz der bildungsauftrag erreger ist
das darf man ja auch nicht vergesse
yahoo und die lehrerinnen und lehrer
sind eben der verlängerte arm auch in
dem bereich wie bei der polizei auch und
da gehört sich das einfach in der
höflichkeit form zu sprechen um die
nötigen respekt liebe ja die alte
skifahrer regel ab 1000 meter wird
geduzt ja ansonsten finde ich kann man
sich im sport generell wird nur genutzt
also ich mach zwei mal die woche
boxtraining da duzen sich alle
da muss man schwer aufpassen dass man
sich hätte ein
gerade aus minister mit der bisherige
der wird auch genutzt heiko maas ist ein
neuer commerce
one box sehr gut der boxt nicht
sonderlich gut der hat aber eine sehr
gute figur weil der fünf kämpfer war die
figur hat er mitgenommen in seine ämter
und die hat er sich erhalten das sind ja
gut aus wenn man ihn sieht ja kurze
hosen kurzes hemd
fotografen vorbei lieber schwarz
weiß der mine duzen uns zuerst denn
jetzt wenn wenn wir in der schule noch
wehren und wir hätten lehrer die wir
auch thuns nur wenn fenster es gut oder
nicht gut ich will mir wäre das ehrlich
gesagt nicht so wichtig es kam natürlich
auch sein muss man sich ja denken
vielleicht möchte auch nicht jeder
formuliere genutzt werden oder die
lehrer dutzend war das ja auch eine sehr
persönliche ebene schafft so eine
distanz kann ja auch vom schüler mal
gewünscht sein wird aber seine jusos
haben doch auch schon schlimmere sachen
gefordert als jetzt irgendwie zu dürfen
das ist hermann ja das kann man ja mal
anregen ich kenne es wiederum aus der
schule so dass dann wenn wir so in die
oberstufe nein sagen könnten dass die
lehre angefangen haben uns zu sitzen wie
gesagt man hamburger sie
haben aber nach wie genau hat er einmal
gesagt ja
ich muss ich muss gestehen ich habe in
der grundschule mal aus versehen einen
lehrer geduzt also du und dann gesagt
herr von werden kannst du mal werden wir
auch darauf aufmerksam machen ich glaube
es war auch gar nicht so eine schlechte
erziehung dass wenn mein kind auch ins
sofa feld zu sagen es gibt verschiedene
möglichkeiten so ich mich stört aber
daran wirklich viel mehr als sie das so
sehen ob man nutzen sollte oder nicht
weil zum beispiel unternehmen es gibt ja
unternehmen wo geduzt wird von
mainz geschäftsfrau nicht ich sehr
werden dadurch auch nicht volksmehr wenn
sie sich auf einmal nutzen wissen also
zu bestimmten persönlichkeit passt das
einfach nicht und ich hätte in der
schule noch eine eins nämlich dass
lehrer die sich eh nicht gut durchsetzen
können durch ein du dann vollkommen an
respekt verlieren das ist man sie doch
und schwerer haben in der klasse und
ehrlich gesagt dass verwischt ja auch
hierarchien ein lehrer hat in der klasse
einfach das sagen das ist doch so dass
muss er es doch nicht sein kumpel ich
meine da gibt den noten und er sollte
etwas beibringen warum sollen wir denn
da jetzt plötzlich auf einer ebene seien
das verstehe ich gar nicht habe früher
immer gehört also ich habe erlebt dass
lehrer den schülern angeboten haben aber
erst in den oberen klassen sie zu duzen
dann haben sie haben sie aber selber
entschieden sie das wollten dass man
auch junge lehrer
und da wurde immer gesagt man sagt eben
sehr viel schneller du idiot als idiot
und deshalb ist es wichtig vielleicht
bei dem sie zu bleiben weil ansonsten
die schimpfwörter spacken und ähnliches
zu jedem schneller wenn man duzt backen
auch ausschnitte hinaus zu hören ja er
wurde um gottes willen ich hatte ja und
ich glaube kritische auseinandersetzung
schwierige themen schwierige
diskussionen sind teilweise besser wenn
man sich einfach mehr besser zu führen
der und schule ist ein übungsraum
schulen auf das leben vorbereiten dazu
gehört auch dass die kinder lernen wie
gehe ich mit autoritäten
einen polizisten aber so nutzen oder so
dass er die kantersiege du frau frau
sowieso oder in der grundschule ist das
ja teilweise so dann wären sie darauf
hingewiesen
genau das verstehen die dann irgendwann
und lernen dass auch und dann sind sie
eben auch vorbereitet auf das echte
leben da draußen denn auch schule ist
eine art von echtem leben da draußen und
ist dazu da die kinder für einige wird
es immer autoritäten geben und wenn du
früh schon lernst dass es keine
autoritäten gibt wie willst du das dann
später den canon bei repo autoritäten es
gibt ja ein filmprojekt über kevin
kühnert der ist ja glaube ich über ein
jahr lang von dem fernsehteam begleitet
worden bei allen möglichen internen
gesprächen usw
wer die zeit hat sich das anzugucken ich
habe sie nicht der sollte sich das
angucken aber ich weiß was da drin ist
ja unter anderem sitzt er mit den beiden
parteivorsitzenden zusammen
walter-borjans und esken und sagt denen
die haben ein block in der hand wie bei
kimmel zungen in nordkorea glocken hand
und schreiben mit was der vorsitzende
sagt so war das da und er sagt den was
sie zu tun haben und wie sie zu
formulieren haben und wie sie sich zu
verhalten haben und wie sie lächeln
sollen usw das zum thema wer kommt in
der spd nach den beiden also irgendwann
kommt sicher kevin kühnert entweder als
vorsitzender oder gleich als kann zwar
wo die wette geduld haben sich auch das
ganz sicher die genossen duzen sich alle
wobei die diskussion an sich ist toll
also ich liebe das immer wenn man über
sprache diskutiert weil sprache lebendig
ist und sich immer weiterentwickeln muss
insofern ist auch das wieder total toll
sowie mit den ganzen begriffen die wir
haben ich mag diese diskussionen an sich
aber ich denke das wäre es wäre schade
wir haben aber noch nicht diskutiert
sondern er hat
[Musik]